Speaker 1: All right. I don't know why I
find this next clip so damn funny, but I
was laughing hysterically this morning watching
this. There's this kooky Republican Congressman
James Comer. James Comer is obsessed with talking
about how they're going to go after Joe Biden.
They're going to investigate this. They're going
to get. They're going to get Biden's family. Now,
you all know that. That's ridiculous. But James
Colmer appeared last night on the HANNITY Fox News
program. I guess the HANNITY Fox News program now
is shot with a live audience. And despite there
being no evidence of crimes committed by the Biden
family, Colmer is claiming to be super confident
that they are closing in. The walls are closing in
on the Biden family. So this is this is a silly,
nonsensical thing. But Hannity's crowd starts
cheering when he says it. They just cheer.
Do they not realize that the walls aren't
closing in on the Biden family? I don't
know. But there's a little detail that I
don't know why this is so funny. When the
crowd starts cheering and this is very visual.
So I'll describe it to people who are listening
when Colmer says this. The crowd starts cheering.
The camera pans to the live audience for Hannity's
show. And you see two people. I don't know
if they're a couple or if they just happened
to be sitting next to each other and they are
clapping and chewing gum so aggressively. Why
are you chewing gum at a live taping of a TV show?
Like, I don't I don't know why I find it so weird,
but I could not stop laughing when I saw this this
morning. Check this out. It's all ridiculous. The
the walls are closing in. No, they're not. The
crowd cheering What you guys do? You guys believe
this? But the gum chewing is just too much for me.
Speaker 5: It all points back to Joe Biden. And
we're going to continue until we get the truth
to the American people. But I can say this shot,
the walls are closing in on the Biden family
members, soldiers who can be with us. Thank
you. Look at the people chewing gum.
Speaker 1:
They look like ruminants chewing their cud. What
the guy on the screen left, the gum is sticking
out of his mouth. Why? Why is there so much gum
chewing happening during this show? And of course,
the truth is the walls are not closing in on
Joe Biden's family. If they're closing in,
they're closing in at what we might call a glacial
pace. Well, we might have the next we might have
the next Ice Age or Trump's health care plan
before the Bidens actually end up indicted.
So people very excited. On the HANNITY program
for something they're being told is happening,
which simply is not happening. I'm not a betting
man, but that's something I'm willing to bet on.
Now, of course, remember, I'm for Law and order,
so I say if there is evidence of criminality.
Against anyone, whether it's a Democratic
president, a Republican president,
a Speaker of the House or vice president, if
there's evidence that someone committed a crime.
Investigate it. If you find that, indeed, it
looks like they did commit a crime, charge them.
Try them. I'm not saying don't do it. I'm
just saying I don't believe that there is
going to be any evidence that the Biden family
committed any crimes. All right. Let's move on.